what is being called the great las vegas
coffee shop giveaway is down to just a
handful of finalists six restaurant
concepts are competing for a chance to
have their ideas brought to life at the
historic hundred shopping center which
is over at charleston maryland so
tonight the very first group of these
finalists served its menu to the public
this is inside the vegas test kitchen
which is downtown this is the random act
diner they were showcasing things like
pb and j with bacon and also ube
pancakes now if selected as the winners
staff also want to offer entertainment
our hope is that for every 15 minutes
that there is a 90-second play musical
play
it just kind of takes
the norm out of
randomness like have you enjoy a
milkshake and and you know
french fries and all of a sudden what's
going on the bartender is singing
being part of the musical play
so if you miss them tonight you can
check out random act diner tomorrow from
two to nine again open to the public now
so here are the other five finalists
each will get a weekend uh friday and
saturday to serve up their menu and then
after that a winner is going to be
chosen and we will be following that
journey nice i'm